[Music]
have you ever
have you ever been on a plane and you go
into the john
and somebody had just taken a [ __ ]
yes dude that was i had massive diarrhea
and i always used to be the guy that's
like who [ __ ]
from the back all the way down yeah
how was that guy you were the guy i was
that guy but the airplane that
questioned yourself
you like walking there i do it i had one
of those like you did it explosive
diarrhea is where it's like
on the way down and i was like
bro and i look back from the yeah
and you know what though i wiped that
[ __ ] down
on the inside like on the on the top of
the seat yeah because you know how the
way
the flush system works on the toilet in
the in an airplane right it just sucks
it sucks so hard it uses air yeah so
kaka was lined up all over the [ __ ]
bowl
oh yeah water doesn't get to that you
know what i said i
i got a bunch of toilet paper with that
[ __ ] and threw it on top
so it holds on top of it yeah and then
i hit the flush and it took it literally
like the air
took it as a sponge and took it down and
i was like thank god i have a question i
think that's that's dope i have a
question that's first class
when you go to a bathroom and they're
[ __ ] caked on the toilet do you guys try
to pee it off
if i can get it all off i'm pretty proud
of myself yeah dude i'm like yo my
stream is
good pressure washing videos very
satisfying and you got to like be kind
of strategic with the pressure right
and you have to you have to mix forever
yeah because sometimes your strategy is
[ __ ] up sometimes you start too early
too low
and then you gotta distribute the pia
you were like jacking off the night
before and then there's like crusty and
then so your pee like goes this way
oh [ __ ] yeah it splits yeah dude if i
brought
the whole toilet i would have walked out
of there and been like who who could
have done such a thing
because i believe in toilet karma yeah i
mean when i started cleaning up after
myself
what i realized is i've been very lucky
with public bathrooms me too man
me too so i'm like toilet karma i'm a
guy i have not so i'm definitely living
in my karma
that's okay though that's cool uh so a
plane a british airways flight
um was headed from heathrow to dubai
seven hour flight
and all of a sudden everyone started to
notice
a pretty rough smell oh no coming from
one of the toilets i wonder how many
hours in
uh these that matter so well yeah there
was like altitude
they must have been bad if it was one of
the toilets seeping
the whole airplane up you can't smell
[ __ ] in there they got all the
they weren't that far away they were
about 30 minutes out uh
but they decided to turn around that's
how
bad it was couldn't get rid of it i
didn't even know the plane would turn
around over
was it was it because of cocka over some
[ __ ] it's just
it was just a regular [ __ ] in the toilet
situation it wasn't even
just because somebody wrecked the toilet
dude one time i'd be so mad
i had a flight back from japan and the
man sitting right behind like
it smelled like [ __ ] dude and i felt so
bad for the people behind me
and when that guy got up to go to the
bathroom i heard him in japanese they're
like
his uh another passenger was telling the
other person like
like damn dude it sounds it smells like
you're suffering over there and he goes
man
i i want to die
that's i i heard them every [ __ ] i
feel i feel like that in some uber rides
some uber rides i'm like do you
purposely not
shower and then rub your scalp all over
this entire car
some cars you get into it and it just
smells so well that's the thing about
scent right it's like
you can't really smell how bad you are
yeah and if you could smell it through a
face mask
it's really bad you're right at the
grocery store and you smell somebody
like oh my it's always old people
but it's always like holy god yeah
they're rotting from the inside
yeah it's crazy yeah they smell like
people fart anytime too
i mean i fart any time you don't fart
any time
i mean now or anytime when i was a kid i
was looking at nintendo games and i was
squatted down
and this old man with his ass right here
just let one rip
my [ __ ] bangs forever that's why
they're so good though
the hemispheres of my swirly the
trajectory
and then you turn to ryan exactly
because of that guy's [ __ ] fart
it melted your hair in one place it was
like a permanent purple i was like
that was like a superhero moment yeah my
origin story
the fart where yeah that's
that's not right and then i saw he was
so [ __ ] old so what am i how you
gonna get mad at an old guy for farting
he probably doesn't even know he did it
he thinks i did it he doesn't know i can
get mad at anybody for any reason i'm
pretty good
that's that's your superhero farted just
by trying to gain balance again he's
about to fall over
oh legends oh [ __ ] like the spacesuits
that have thrusters
he's just like do you think you just
stopped giving a [ __ ] at that age
or your [ __ ] bro i think it's a bit
of both i feel like if you don't
give a [ __ ] if you don't use it you lose
it i already barely give a [ __ ]
it might have been a racial situation i
have no idea yeah oh
he's looking for this little asian kid's
head he's like farting all the way back
to manila i think my heart
is not for me right it's like out of
respect for other people yeah but when
i'm older i'm not going to respect
anybody
that's true that's true yeah they don't
respect you exactly
i know how we feel about old people it's
pretty crazy yeah
every time i'm behind them and anything
car
grocery store line i'm always like [ __ ]
but when they're cool they're cool
though
they're cool but when they're shitty oh
get rid of them when they're pulling out
the coupons from their wallet
now here we go if it's not santa claus
a wizard uh grandma making cookies
[ __ ] them all see a harry potter wizard
particularly right you got to bring
something to the table a martial arts
master seafood that doesn't speak
pokemon i'm down with that will you let
him fart in your face if it's part of my
training
yeah if it's part of training what about
a mysterious old man who sends you on a
journey
that's cool wizard that's cool oh that's
just a little wizard yeah that's a
wizard
yeah yeah so yeah like like a kung fu
master
he looks like a frail old man but when
he takes off his shirt he has a six-pack
yeah see that's different beer yeah if
he's bald with a long beard that he
[ __ ] with all day
that's cool i felt threatened by an old
man recently i was coming in i was in
like hollywood and i was coming from a
store to pick some stuff
out and there's this old man just
standing on the side in the residential
area that's where i parked
and he's like i couldn't really
understand what he was saying but he's
like can you help me turn something on
in my house like i i can't get it
scan your house bro yeah and i just was
like what he goes i need someone to help
me he had an accent i don't know where
he was from
he's like can you help me push this
button inside my home and i was like
hell no i think it was hitting on me no
thank you yeah yeah man i should have my
back then
i should have she putting in my home
scary [ __ ]
and it was very specific where i just
couldn't understand and then i
i was like i'm sorry i can't i gotta go
and this other dude walked up and was
like oh i could help and i was like
sucker and i left and that guy has never
seen her hurt he's dead bro
that guy inherited that old man's entire
mansion [ __ ] dude
i know at least ted bundy did i was like
hey i might
i have a car that you know it's hurt or
more believable
my tires flat the ten body was hot well
that too
yeah it was just pretty hot though he
was pretty hot he was gonna
have a button that needs to be pushed
and i was like what kind of button he's
like let me show you yeah that's sexual
innuendo
let me see a picture you when you were
young and then we'll see
who's pushing what do you ever find it
odd that
that your parents were young and when
you see pictures you don't really
believe it
yeah yeah yeah that happens to me all
the time i don't really believe it it's
like i see it but i don't know that i
100
accept that they were ever my age i
don't like that my dad was hotter than
me
really based on he gets a lot of uh
says who though says you're on instagram
and everyone was saying how hot he was
and then i realized yeah but he's also
harder than me
he's taller he's handsomer yeah you
think though bro yeah
[ __ ] him and his guitar too yeah but hey
what's funny now is that
i'm hotter than him now that's all that
matters yeah he aged like [ __ ] didn't he
it's like [ __ ]
he's got like no hair he's got like
nothing but wrinkles i'm hotter than him
now
yeah piece of [ __ ] i hear the stories
that i compare though i'm like [ __ ]
that's crazy because like
my dad would tell me when i was when i
was 15 that when he was 15 that's when
he escaped communist china
him in like six people yeah but you're
stealing cars at 15.
you guys are both wild ones yeah they're
all like they're like going through the
mountains and stuff escaping like
national guards and stuff
and you know yeah you're when you're
when you're that age like oh my god
[Applause]
30 something you know i'm like [ __ ] a 15
year old just
going through a [ __ ] forest like that
that's
crazy like dad don't you dare call
taiwan country bro
because you can't ever bro that's true
how do you make the decision at 15 to
leave your country
it's gotta be so bad yeah it's gonna be
so [ __ ] bad there's some reason
because he wanted to be an engineer and
then they made him a farmer and he's
like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
so that's one of them i mean junior high
he i think him and his best friend he
was like really good at math and physics
his buddies
got like c's and [ __ ] and then my dad
was supposed to be sent to the
to do field work and his buddy got
assigned to be an engineer
and he was like what the [ __ ] that's
like one of the
like red flags and then uh my dad was
saying like um
you know pretty much every all they ate
every day was just half a bowl of rice
and half a bowl of rice all right like
they barely had anything it's a
supermodel diet
they eat better on survivor dude yeah
they barely had any food
and he only had one set of uniforms so
he literally would wear that to school
when he comes home
he washes it and he's just in his
underwear the whole day while the
clothes are drying and he wears the
exact same thing the next day so
no food no clothes no nothing
and like they would everyone would
scrounge up money to get one cigarette
and they would all split hits like
across all the kids
we were doing the same [ __ ] at 15. yeah
that cigarette hit though yeah this is
when he was like eight
oh eight yeah eight years old splitting
cigarettes with people and i'm like damn
actually it was crazy when you got the
money together and you took that first
hit
and he made the right choice because i
heard a lot of dudes his generation when
they were field workers they ended up
dying
because of famine oh yeah so
it's crazy yeah and i'm like damn when
you think back yeah that's what a 15
year old went through
some crazy [ __ ] did that make you smoke
a cigarette at eight years old no
he did make me drink a beer when i was
15. you guys need to stop being a [ __ ]
you need to man the [ __ ] up
she got me a budweiser and i drank it i
remember i like got a headache
and i had like a boner so i went to go
sleep and then i was like oh this feels
so weird my dick's hard
my dad's just laughing like he's like
you're not a man
your dad should probably go to ucla to
talk to all the kids about the benefits
of socialism
yeah that'd be classic
[ __ ] that's so crazy to even think about
yeah he was part of the whole school
shutdowns
burning of books like just in the middle
of the street take all the books all the
intellect that we have
oh you saw the mao revolution she saw
all that were they just light books on
fire
toppling statues yo if i was at eight
and i saw
books being burnt i would have been like
no hall
revolution that's what ellie riots felt
you